so you do that search with let's say uh
safaris they will then fire up another
browser somewhere virtually in their
cloud system
ask the search engine for that
use their ip address and then send you
the result back is that kind of what's
happening
is that a description of it
not not exactly and i don't want to
misspeak on apple's product okay it
seems kind of complicated but um
in general i think they're trying to
help protect your ip address from
when you go to websites um that's one
method of tracking unfortunately to be
like fully protected you really need um
tracker blocker
as well
um because you know there's a lot of
ways to get fingerprinted when you load
up explain this this is
a critically important concept my
understanding is your screen resolution
your monitor setup your memory
a lot of other pieces uh to do with your
browser and your desktop
or your phone can be sent to build a
profile of you explain how they build
these modern day profiles if they don't
have your ip address
yeah it's a it's a bit counter-intuitive
um but it's true uh your computer is
pretty unique it's really what it is um
like the fonts you have installed and
the combination of what version you're
using and kind of exactly what model it
is and what the screen size is when you
add up all those little pieces and say
you say you put it together in one long
number your number is often unique to
you and so you can use that as as a
fingerprint
which means that they could turn it into
an id kind of like an ip address and
follow you around with that or even
easier
you know you can just
drop make up a unique number and drop it
as a cookie um
but like what happens is as long as
these scripts can load these trackers
like say like google analytics
they're going to find a way to
fingerprint you and so the key is
actually blocking them from loading on
the websites you visit you need that
extreme level of blocking and that's
what a good like tracker blocker like
ours that component will do versus just
like when you hear all this talk about
we're just restricting cookies or
you know we're just
putting restrictions on these trackers
that's not going to go far enough to
actually stop the harm like they'll
still be able to track you
okay so apple has been doing tons of
these privacy things you've been doing
ton of privacy things brave browser a
lot of people vpns nordvpn tunnelbear
everybody's really getting in on this
trying to really protect people's
privacy and i think your timing was
great you were too early at the
beginning and now it seems like
consumers are catching up to this
concept uh because of data leaks because
of regulations and just all kinds of bad
actors and what they're seeing in the
world
people seem to care about that what what
percentage of people would you say
are um
concerned enough about privacy to take
uh initiative get a vpn use one of these
browsers versus people who maybe are you
know more passive about it where are we
at today in 2021
yeah that's a that's a great way to put
it that's exactly how we um look at our
market we call it the care and act on
privacy group so yeah you don't just say
you care but you actually took some
action um
that is actually just across 50 percent
of the us of people who are attempting
to do something like you said some
action
um so it's a lot i think the the gap
there is in the quality of the software
and so it's our job to make that simple
and seamless and that is our real goal
is to be that easy button so when people
are looking they can just download our
product at any platform and get that
basic protection
so here's a candid question apple
duckduckgo you're perfectly aligned
there's some potico you share the same
vision
yet
apple gives gets 15 billion dollars a
year from google to make them the
default search engine it's a nice chunk
of change it's a pretty penny
um you purposely monetize at a lower
level than google google makes about 30
cents a search i think i'm guessing you
make 10 of that
am i in the ballpark here that you
monetize we definitely make a lot less
so just go with that 80 less something
like that because you just are not
flooding the top with 20 links there and
you're flooding with two one or you're
putting one or two they're putting 20.
so i'm just i'm going to say 10 percent
maybe you make three cents per search on
average to their 36 pick a number right
there
apple if they made you the default it
means they would go from 15 billion
dollars a year and you might generate a
1.5 billion dollars if you had all those
apple consumers or let's say you do
really good you double that
they don't need that incremental 10
billion dollars i don't think why don't
they uh just make you the default search
engine and there's been rumors and
advocacy around them buying duckduckgo
what are your thoughts on a potential
deeper collaboration with apple
i mean we've been pushing for a third
option uh you know both to partners but
also just in a regulatory manner which
is
you know that deal is a deal of a
default deal that google's kind of
locked up not just on apple but
basically all defaults on most phones
and
missing all of android through all of
the handset deals
and so what we'd actually like is
instead of that is for there to be what
we call a preference menu when you
install the device or open up even
chrome for the first time you're
presented with an option to to pick the
search engine so you know most people
are using google now
never made a choice they just got google
and that's what they've gotten for the
last you know 20 years um but we think
that if people really understood
that there was another option and would
be easily able to check it out like our
our percentage would go up overnight and
so from apple's perspective or anyone's
it's more we think of more from the
consumer perspective of giving
users a choice that want it you know
anyone who really wants privacy making
it easy this is a brilliant uh framing
of the issue because what you're saying
is let consumers choose and
what google has done is
because they are willing to
uh compromise people's privacy at the
highest level
they then have the budget
to pay off partners at the highest level
because you do the right thing you make
three cents a search i'm saying that i'm
making it up to my estimate they make 30
cents therefore you could never offer an
android headset maker apple whoever the
same deal that google could so we've
created an incentive structure here
which means the more you invade people's
privacy the more you build a profile of
them that they clearly don't want
even somebody like apple
who has made it their mission the last
two or three years to protect people's
privacy even they can't say no to the
massive
buckets and wheelbarrows and just dump
trucks dump trucks going from mountain
view to cupertino there's garbage trucks
of a hundred dollar bills being dumped
in front of the apple campus isn't that
what's happening here
i think that speaks to why you know the
market is broken there it's a it's
really a monopoly issue and it needs an
anti-trust remedy
of you know getting rid of these search
defaults and letting consumers choose
that would be our goal
if you're a startup founder you know
that